welcome to Hannity we start tonight with
a Fox News Alert tonight major breaking
news a bombshell new letter from
congressman Devin Nunez surrounding a
shady foreign figure named Joseph Huff
Sid who is closely linked to the origins
of the FBI's Russia witch-hunt
Muller's report portrayed him as an
academic with ties to russian
intelligence but congressman Nunez his
letter well it makes clear he may also
have connections to Western governments
that raises many questions about just
how this Russia investigation got
started whether Western intelligence
services including our own may have been
compromised
wet weather intelligence gathering was
outsourced to bypass American laws now
congressman Nunez will be here in just a
moment with a lot more also tonight we
will show you how James Comey Hillary
Clinton the Obama administration and of
course their best friends the media
mobbed work in concert to create and
then perpetrate a hoax against Donald
Trump and you we the American people
before we get to all that breaking news
I want to you know listen closely
because I know you will not hear this
good news from any other news source
today's economic news is more than
phenomenal we have an economy that is
roaring and booming like never before
look at these numbers they speak for
themselves
unemployment 3.6 percent that is a 49
year low we are now witnessing the
lowest hispanic unemployment ever in our
history we're seeing historic lows for
women in the workplace african-americans
asian-americans youth unemployment
record levels of jobs for high school
dropouts and those without a college
education
nationwide income is seeing significant
increases that means yes the Forgotten
men and women the stock market is
soaring the u.s. is now an net exporter
of oil and gas we are energy independent
for the first time in 75 years and that
of course a major national security win
by the way against the hostile actor
Putin and the hostile regime of Russia
and their oil
based alagar key in fact exports of
American liquefied natural gas to Europe
is now increased by nearly 300 percent
after the president negotiated new trade
deals in this case with the EU and while
Europe's economy look at this last two
quarters their GDP growth Wow a whopping
Leeloo 0.4 percent following 0.2 percent
that's the last two quarters the last
six months our first quarter growth 3.2
percent during a government shutdown as
drug George said today the envy of the
world now in the Trump economy everybody
wins
American greatness is returning so with
the 2020 election right around the
corner what is the Democratic message
fear division the world ending in ten
years no more oil gas cows planes or air
combustion engine in 2020 this will be a
huge choice election
all we better off than we were four
years ago Biden going to defend the
economic record of eight years of him
and Obama okay also in the meantime
we've got to get to the bottom of what
was the single biggest abuse of power
scandal in this country's history now
for years this country's most sensitive
and powerful intelligence tools were
turned against its own citizens by a few
not the majority
the Trump campaign the Trump transition
team we now know it is now beyond all
doubt incontrovertible evidence they
were spied on by the Obama
administration not once but over and
over again American rights were trampled
the Constitution shredded lives were
ruined a partisan Special Counsel
witch-hunt divided this country for
almost two years
in the end thankfully truth prevailed
they lost no collusion the less long con
hoax conspiracy theories whether they
can admit it or not the Attorney General
confirmed this week they are over but
stage 2 the second act begins officially
as he said this week everything we've
been talking about for two years the
Attorney General will begin
investigating and already has watch this
there's been no president in here
street that has given what I've given in
terms of looking at just a total witch
hunt there I caught the Russian hoax it
turned out to be no collusion no
obstruction it was a total hoax and yet
I was transparent we gave one point four
million documents we gave hundreds of
people I let him interview the lawyer
the White House lawyer for 30 hours
think of that 30 hours
I let him interview other people I
didn't have to let him interview anybody
I didn't have to give any documents I
was totally transparent because I knew I
did nothing wrong
it turned out I did nothing wrong not
once to this administration invoke
executive privilege they could have
literally done it every step of the way
they did not and the search for justice
is only beginning as confirmed by the
Attorney General this week operation
crossfire hurricane it is now officially
the beginning of Operation boomerang
because while these bad actors at the
highest levels of our government were
steadfastly accusing the president of
misdeeds they were the ones committing a
litany of real crimes which will be
proven President Trump is calling it now
a scandal bigger than Watergate I'd say
way bigger and of course we're not
talking about the rank and file the 99%
of investigators in the premiere law
enforcement agency in the world the FBI
premier intelligence agency the CIA
there is outrage as we are instead we're
talking about a few select power-hungry
self-aggrandizing those that view
themselves as super Patriots that think
we don't know better
those that literally rigged an
investigation into Hillary tried to rig
an election and then set up the Trump
campaign with an insurance policy and
tried to take down a duly elected
President of the United States let's
start with a basic and fundamental truth
it's so simple even these lazy overpaid
members of the so-called media so-called
journalists so-called newsrooms that 99%
of them that got it all wrong and lied
to everybody
the Trump campaign was spied on that
evidence is incontrovertible the New
York time
even admitting something this program
has now been covering for years with a
report that now details how commis FBI
in fact it's deeper than we thought they
sent an undercover investigator posing a
as a research assistant meeting with
Trump aide George papadopolis in 2016 by
the way the undercover agent set up the
meeting in London between herself a
30-year old blonde are making it known
she's available with Papadopoulos and
Stefan Helper who we've talked about at
length who was working as a secret FBI
informant this discussion was supposed
to involve foreign policy strategies but
it soon took a weird unusual turn it was
all about Russia Russia Russia Russia
and Trump Trump Trump and whether the
Trump campaign was actually working with
Vladimir Putin and that's not all gets
more bizarre the undercover agent was
apparently trying to flirt and seduce
the Trump campaign advisor George
papadopolis he's here tonight to tell us
this story in detail and so will Carter
page by the way who was also spied on by
Halper and Sam Clovis as well now the
FBI was spying on pages phone calls and
emails after he was wiretap pursuing to
a FISA warrant as we all know by now
that was first signed by James Comey
based on Hillary's bought and paid for
Russian dirty dossier that even the New
York Times is suggesting might have been
Russian disinformation the same dossier
put together with Russian lies and
Google searches by a former spy British
mi6 officer Christopher Steele a
document that according to the New York
Times could have itself and
disinformation from Russia and now it's
the subject of an investigation
currently being conducted by the
Attorney General remember he said this
week he's not changing his mind on
Muller it's over it's done it's finished
anything you hear from here on in his
noise what he says now is what the
second act is going to be all about what
we've been telling you take a look how
do we know that the spilled dossier is
not itself evidence
of Russian disinformation campaign
knowing what we know now that basically
the allegations made in their--in were
secondhand hearsay or unverified to my
state with confidence that the Russian
that the steel dossier was not part of
the Russian disinformation campaign no I
can't state that with confidence and and
that is one of the areas that I'm
reviewing I'm concerned about it and and
and I don't think it's entirely
speculative this is only the tip of the
iceberg between the da see the phony
Russian dossier investigation we have
bars investigation into spying FISA
abuse FISA Court fraud that
investigation the investigation into
leaking so many of the probes and why
did they rig the Hillary Clinton
investigation in other words we must get
to the bottom of what was the biggest
abuse of power scandal in history if we
do not we can no longer consider
ourselves a constitutional republic we
will then be a Banana Republic the Vice
President of the United States is vowing
to do just that take a look we've got to
get to the bottom of how all this
started I mean the American people have
a right to know how this investigation
even began and and as the Attorney
General said when he testified before
Congress there was spying we need to
understand why there he was whether
there was a sufficient predicate well I
think we need to find out we really need
to get to the bottom of how this all
began and if there was a violation of
the rules if the law was broken the
people that were responsible need to be
held accountable and by the way get this
hell is frozen over you even have a host
a conspiracy TV MSNBC they might be
starting to see the light only one
though don't don't looks like it carried
away here now actually agreeing with the
vice president that's spying a Kurt
remember there's but nothing but
conspiracy theories every second minute
hour of every day for two years on this
conspiracy TV channel take a look but
let me start with a central question on
a lot of people's minds last night as
they first read it and as they read it
this morning how was this not spot
well I guess it depends on your
definition of spine now this has
significant serious ramifications for
the 2020 election by the way not looking
good for creepy crazy Uncle Joe after
all he was in the meetings with Comey
and Obama and rice about the dirty
dossier at the height of the
administration spying what did he know
when did he know it and let's not forget
about Biden's incredibly shady dealings
with the Ukraine which we chronicled
last night according to the New York
Times he did use his position as the
vice president he threatened to withhold
our money the taxpayers money a billion
dollars in u.s. loan guarantees if
Ukraine's leaders did not in six hours
dismiss the country's top prosecutor
prosecutor who we now know is
investigating corruption accusations a
Ukrainian energy firm where Biden's son
served on the board
make no mistake Joe Biden is corrupt he
has many questions to answer a career
politician and by the way with the worst
economic record worst recovery in 40
years and eight years of Obama Biden 13
million more Americans on food stamps 8
million war on poverty and compare it to
the Trump economy right now all these
records being broken and speaking of
which Hillary Clinton well she and her
fellow Democrats were accusing president
Trump of colluding with the foreign
government during the election we now
know they were the ones who are actually
doing the colluding look at this damning
report from the hills John Solomon
Ukraine's embassy in the US is accusing
the DNC of trying to coordinate with
their government to affect the
presidential election DNC contractor
allegedly quote tried to arrange for
Ukrainian president to comment on Paul
Manafort Russian ties on a u.s. visit
during the 2016 campaign and there's
email evidence and as you can see the
left has a lot to be worried about
tonight they were the ones using the
most sensitive powerful tools in our
federal government as a political weapon
turning it on the American people to
bludgeon the
candidate they didn't like I get vote in
favor of the candidate they thought
should win a hundred million a zero and
they had an insurance policy after and
after all we're just a bunch of smelly
Walmart voters what what what do we know
they knew better they're the super
Patriots they were the ones that
actually were colluding with a foreign
government digging up dirt collusion to
help impact an election they're the ones
that have divided this country now for
over two years with lie after lie after
lie and what is a full-on hoax they're
the ones as former Clinton pollster Mark
Penn put it they are the ones
weaponizing our political system against
itself and now they are the ones lashing
out trying to distract from their crimes
and according to a great new op-ed from
Kimberly straw so in The Wall Street
Journal the Attorney General bar is now
getting attacked because his probe
endangers very powerful people she will
also be with us in a moment but now the
actions of Hillary Clinton James Comey
Andrew McCabe Joe Biden Bruce and Nellie
or Peter struck Lisa page Susan Rice and
that means clapper and Brennan and
either and even the former President
himself Obama are now coming into focus
and we will need and we will get answers
and sunlight is the best disinfectant
the pendulum is now swung the boomerang
in full motion the Muller issue is dead
overdone completed Act two now begins
and we better get it right or we lose
the country we love forever